Por cada 3 horas de juegos de computadora,
Sandra tiene 2 horas de tarea.
Por cada 7 horas de juegos de computadora,
Madison tiene 4 horas de tarea.
¿Qué punto puede decirnos cuántas horas de tarea tuvo Sandra si jugó juegos de computadora por 5 horas?
Tenemos esta gráfica y tenemos estás dos líneas.
Primero tenemos que determinar si este eje
son las horas de tarea
y este eje son las horas de computadora,
¿cuál linea le pertenece a quién?
Entonces, si Sandra tiene 2 horas de tarea
por cada 3 horas de juegos de computadora,
si me voy a este punto que son 2 horas de
tarea y me muevo a esta altura,
¿qué gráfica me daría una coordenada "x" de 3?
Esta gráfica roja me señalaría que por
2 horas de tarea, tendría 3 horas de juegos
de computadora y por lo tanto le pertenece a Sandra.
Ahora, me preguntan, ¿qué punto puede decirnos cuántas horas de tarea tuvo Sandra
si jugó juegos de computadora por 5 horas?
Me voy a 5 horas de juegos de computadora
y subo a la gráfica de Sandra,
que es la gráfica roja y llego al punto C.
Así que la respuesta debe ser C.
¡En efecto!